6en y en a beaucoup qui en profitent
pour faire du camping oui oui et souvent
qu est ce qu on entend les ours sont
approchés des maisons ou des temps et il
faut faire attention avec la nourriture
ne pas la laisser à l'extérieur alors à
yellowstone une parc national ont fait
des tests alors on veut avoir des
équipements et surtout des glacières ou
peut-être même des poubelles
éventuellement l'amérique sont à l'abri
des ours à 70 mm d'épaisseur peu puisque
deux pouces et puis si l'ours réussi à
atteindre à nourriture à l'intérieur en
60 minutes c'est pas bon travail en
travaillant fort appétit toujours par
des oursins luis et on sait jamais un
but comme ça c'est ça ça peut faire pas
quand on les voit peu trop près donc
voilà c'est lola je pense qu'on va lire
travailler dessus